ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is
Charles Xavier help is on the way doing
space missions now cool we get the
astronauts we bring them home go heat
signatures rising fast we gotta get out
of here where's Jean
where is she
she should be dead did you hear what the
kids are calling you
Phoenix hello gene
are you the better question is who are
you
something's happening to me you lose
control bad things happen but it feels
good that power destroyed everything
that ever came into contact with until
you the Paxman fear you and what they
fear we seek to destroy shockula's ooh
a girl dies
she's still off that she's not Jean
anymore
are you threatening me that's right
hi everyone its charlie we got brand-new
x-men Dark Phoenix trailer footage to
breakdown Kevin Feige has officially
explained what his plan for the x-men
are during Marvel phase 4 so I explained
that and we're only a week away from
Avengers endgame hitting theaters so it
is all blowing up right now to say
nothing of sophie turner obviously Dark
Phoenix in Game of Thrones Season eight
which is also happening right now if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos is
only gonna get crazier with even more
cool stuff coming out as we head into
the summer and because of endgame
there's a new brand of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave an x-men or
Avengers comment on the video so what
I'll do is I'll talk about the brand new
footage in this trailer first then I'll
talk about what Kevin Feige has said
about Marvel phase 4 and what's gonna be
different about the x-men and those
plans the new trailer is just a little
more polished they've finished more of
the special effects like if you look at
the older trailers the actual effects of
the Phoenix force itself look a little
bit different so that's gotten better as
we're getting closer to the release they
give you more parts of the scenes that
add context to what's going on in outer
space and how she gets the Phoenix force
and more that really big train action
scene where magneto comes to try and
kill Jean Grey the x-men are headed into
outer space in the Blackbird to help
NASA who has encountered the Phoenix
force which is destroying their Space
Shuttle without them realizing what's
going on the back story that Jessica
Chastain's alien quote-unquote character
gives us during the trailer this Delvin
confirm who she's playing but she's
definitely an alien from outer space
trying to co-op the Phoenix force
whether she's a scroll just
shape-shifted into human form or if
she's a member of the Shiar Empire a la
Dark Phoenix from the comics they have
another funny moment trying to recruit
Quicksilver to get his help like he
shrugs just like he did in the last
movie okay I guess it sounds cool I'll
help out I'll be in this movie
Nightcrawler teleports Jean Grey over to
the space shuttle and they start porting
astronauts back while Jean Grey tries to
hold the shuttle together with her
telekinesis even without the Phoenix
force she's already an omega-level
mutant she's always been afraid of her
powers the earlier trailers give you a
little more of that back story where she
accidentally kills her parents in that
car accident because she starts hearing
voices in her head and starts freaking
her out the black dust that's floating
around in here before Nightcrawler ports
in is the Phoenix force itself they just
don't understand what
going on it just seems like some space
anomaly that's eating the ship alive as
things go south real fast Nightcrawler
doesn't have time to go back and get
Jean Grey before the shuttle explodes
like they're just measuring some sort of
explosion getting ready to happen but
it's really just the Phoenix force
manifesting and entering her body I'm
not a huge fan of ty Sheridan's version
of Cyclops they're really trying to sell
you on the Cyclops Jean Grae
relationship they had a little bit of
that during x-men apocalypse but I don't
think the movies have had enough time to
establish that I think Hugh Jackman and
James Marsden had better chemistry with
Fon cos version of Jean Grey than ty
Sheridan has with sophie turner so it
was a little easier to swallow some of
those emotional turns and they haven't
done any kind of love triangle in these
newer movies because the Wolverine has
still been the Hugh Jackman version so
obviously they didn't want to do old man
Logan romance love triangle with a
really young version of Jean Grey you
get a little bit more of Jennifer
Lawrence's mystique character with
Professor X just freaking out about what
happened to Jean Grey she should be dead
the other trailers have also sort of
spelled out their history together in
dealing with the Jean Grey character
like mystique is meant to be sort of
their den mother they kind of tried to
set that up during x-men apocalypse but
she's kind of weary of what's going on
with Jean Grey because she was there she
saw the Phoenix force during the last
movie so the way they played in this
movie is that even before she gets the
Phoenix force they're all just a little
bit afraid of her but then they have
that moment with Cyclops you know what
that children are calling you Phoenix I
don't know how I feel about that twist
because the Phoenix force is actually a
conscious entity it actually has a will
of its own it's seeking someone out
until it finds Jean Grey like the way
Jessica Chastain's character explains
it's killed everyone has come into
contact with until you the actual
Phoenix force is the sister of the Shiar
cosmic gods like a legit God so it does
have other names that it goes by but I
just feel like this is them kind of
shoehorning that in because they're not
doing crazy cosmic stuff even though
technically Jessica Chastain is an alien
from outer space I think part of the
reason for that is because they're doing
it as a smaller more self-contained film
within the x-men line of continuity and
in the comics is this big huge infinity
war level event like heaven bah he could
turn around in another ten years and do
another Dark Phoenix saga and do it as
big as they're doing endgame right now
but
I think we're all kind of expecting
Secret Wars to be like their next really
huge 22 film ending saga
I love Magneto's reaction to Jean Grey
here like she comes to Genosha and if it
wasn't clear this is Genosha where
magneto has been since the events of the
last film him seen Jean Grey the danger
she poses is what brings him back into
society like we need to deal with this
it's hard to tell where this standoff
happens where it seems like they're
killing off Jennifer Lawrence's mystique
character like she steps up we're
friends Jean great and then she just
pushes her and you don't see her again
for the rest of the trailer pretty good
sign that it's r.i.p mystique which is a
nice callback to x-men The Last Stand
where Jean Grey kills Professor X inside
her childhood home so I think that's
what they're going for with this scene
here you get a little bit more of what
looks like a subway scene with magneto
taking a subway car and just crashing it
right through what seems like the
x-mansion it's hard to tell what
building this is but it seems like it's
either the x-mansion or some other
really big institutional building the
funny thing about all these train car
scenes like the subway scene and then
the bigger train scene that happens
later in the film is that it reminds you
of the scene from the first x-men film
where magneto rips the train car apart
coming for rogue
[Music]
there's probably gonna be a lot more
callbacks to the other x-men films
because this is the final Fox x-men film
I mean we have new mutants and
technically those are x-men characters
but really this is the last legit Fox
x-men film he tries to enter like a boss
she slaps him around rips his helmet
right off uses it against him and pushes
him through the window with her
telekinesis this scene here where she's
gone full-blown Phoenix and they want to
make it seem like she's getting ready to
kill Cyclops obviously meant to be a big
twist during the film the effects look
really cool but like I said a lot of
this depends on how much you believe in
this Cyclops Jean Grae relationship and
how well they sell it during the film so
they don't have a whole lot of time to
get you on board with that this last
scene of Professor X just getting a full
taste of the Phoenix force while he's
trying to enter Jean Grey's mind while
she's getting the Phoenix force in outer
space this is all happening during the
NASA mission earlier in the trailer but
I do like that title screen in outer
space they actually give you a little
bit of an outline of a Phoenix in space
while the Dark Phoenix title pops up
moving into Marvel phase 4 you may have
heard Kevin Feige talk a little bit
about what his plans are for the x-men
characters now that the merger is
completed he can do whatever he wants to
with them we have endgame coming next
week in Marvel phase 4 we'll start with
spider-man far from home this summer
what he said is is that he had his
Marvel phase 4 plan all mapped out way
before they ever thought about buying
Fox so the x-men are not a big part of
his Marvel phase 4 plans
he made some offhanded remarks about not
seeing x-men in MCU films for a good
long while so that's why you're probably
hearing a lot of news outlets saying
that we're not gonna see x-men in big
Marvel films during Marvel phase 4
that's not entirely true but it's
actually pretty close like we have the
Black Widow movie in the Eternals movie
coming next year probably not gonna see
any x-men during those he said the
Deadpool is gonna be its own thing in
its own level of continuity he's not
gonna mess with Ryan Reynolds so they'll
just continue making those movies doing
whatever they want but now that Disney
has the Fox characters Ryan Reynolds
does get access to MCU characters if
they want to use them in his film the
other really big difference in Marvel
phase 4 than what's come before
is that Kevin Feige said that the
Avengers TV shows that they're making
for the Disney Plus streaming service
like Falcon Winter Soldier the Thor Loki
show the Wanda vision show that's the
name of the Scarlet Witch Vision TV show
Wanda vision those were actually gonna
drive a lot of what happens with the
continuity during phase four so the TV
shows will finally influence what
happens in future movies so the Avengers
TV shows will be a big part of their
Marvel phase four plan not just the
movies whereas traditionally when you
talk about Marvel phase 1 phase 2 phase
3 you're just talking about MCU movies
for those of you asking when the Disney
Plus streaming service is rolling out in
your area around the world this is the
tentative release schedule so some of
the shows won't premiere till like next
year or for another two years so I
wouldn't worry too much about getting
some of this stuff but if there's a show
that premieres before it enters your
area you might be stuck with a VPN
option if you want to watch it with
everyone else but if it wasn't clear
that means if we're not gonna be seeing
a lot of x-men stuff till tail and
Marvel phase four early phase five that
pretty much confirms Kevin Feige is
gonna recast all those characters
including the Wolverine character so I
think we're all on board with the idea
that once they eventually do get around
to doing Avengers secret Wars with a big
multiverse alternate reality story
that's when you bring back the legacy
characters like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Fassbender's magneto James McAvoy
Professor X for cameos but by that time
the main versions of those characters in
our central MCU universe will be played
by different actors so everybody let me
know in the comments below what do you
want them to start with when they get
around to their first MCU x-men or
Fantastic Four film do you want to see
an x-men film first do you want to see
Fantastic Four first what's gonna happen
next is is that I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery review of Avengers endgame
by Tuesday afternoon so that's when
that's gonna happen just look out for it
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see the video when I
post it my end game Easter eggs post
credits scenes spoilery review won't
post til after the movie hits theaters
at the end of next week but all you
gotta do is just make it to next week
we're almost there congratulations
famine X you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for that
brand new Avengers endgame trailer and
click
here for my Game of Thrones Season eight
episode 2 trailer video thank you so
much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]